[Music]
and welcome back y'all to another
episode of the careful boys
today we have mr eric
thank you thank you thank you
so uh what do you do man oh [ __ ] what do
i do this is my first time meeting him
he's got it maybe he's been on here he's
been on here before but for those of you
guys who are also new you might have
have seen him so that's a really good
question what do you do we had eric on
ask the expert yes and he's vietnamese
so we're like probably related no man
we're definitely
[Laughter]
so i do actually a couple of things
besides being an assassin at night time
and a dance floor genius as
he knows a lot of dance moves he said i
actually i actually run a full stack
accounting company and we support a lot
of entity founders entity projects some
of the biggest celebrities and music
artists in the world with their nft
taxes
and
you know pretty much all the big like
empty projects that you know of out
there will probably have a hand in
either helping them do their finances or
act as their cfo wow damn and i'm a
total like jpeg dj and i got way too
many jpegs heck yeah how do you how did
you get into
like
accounting for the crypto nft space
because it just feels like it's so new
yeah but what's crazy it's like when
you're just like the regular like layman
right like you just hear about it you're
like oh okay so i guess nfts is new then
you look deeper and you're like wait
there's already all this staff and stuff
working behind the scenes for the past
five years they're like what the [ __ ]
how do you get into it you know that's a
really good question so like i started
i've been in the accounting space for 14
years now
and i've been in crypto since 2017 like
some of us right we've right we rode
that wave all the way to the oh i know
bro
[Laughter]
but i'm up right now and we're all up
now right when you first bought eth what
was it oh man when i first bought ether
was 346
oh my god man we were mining
my son that we we had we bought like six
graphics cards we had a miner in our
kitchen that was like putting out all
this heat it was just so hot and we're
just mining ethereum we had no idea like
how big it would get we we knew was big
back then but not at this size and scale
yeah and uh we were mining ethereum and
you know that's just how we got into the
space
really cool what was the first entity
did you get a crypto kitty or some [ __ ]
okay so he got a board eight dude
actually the first nft and this is a
this is a weird backwards story right
like so like two years ago my son and i
we lived in bali and then we came back
and then we took this i took this breath
work course where i had to swim hop like
wim hof
and i ended up becoming good friends
with a uh a girlfriend of a massive dj
in las vegas
um and so one day my son are going out
to a car show in las vegas randomly and
we called my buddy i was like hey you
know like let's grab dinner before we
head back to orange county and she's
like why don't you come over steve's
house so i'm just going to drop a first
name right so aoki we were all picked up
all right when you said it we're all
thinking steve wynn huh
he does dj
he is he is quite the dj oh they said
d-gen
so we end up rolling over and it's like
gate after security after security roll
into this dude's house steven's house is
crazy it's crazy
steve harvey idiot
come on guys
and then so we end up like hanging out
and he looks at us and says it was like
midnight this is like after a late car
show he's like he's like hey do you guys
want to do sauna and ice bath cycles and
we're like okay there's a random
question but like yeah sawdust and ice
bath sauna sauna
sawdust ice bath imagine that i'm like
that's some new [ __ ] i've never heard of
that you're not a fitness guru if you've
never heard of the song
that's
we ended up sitting in this like sauna
and we're cooking and we start just
talking about all different stuff and
and steve really starts enjoying the
conversation with my son and we start
talking about crypto and then we jump in
this ice bath thing we're all freezing
our asses off and then he starts talking
about like this project he's dropping
it's his first project this back in
february it's character x on nifty
gateway
and he says hey in a week i'm going to
drop my project
and i was like dude like i've just
gotten to know this guy right so
obviously i'm like oh he's a homie now
right so i'm gonna i'm gonna bind this
nft
we drive back home my son are like i
don't know what just happened we just
hung out this dude's house
um how old is your son by the way he
just turned 18. wow
does he think you're cool or you think
you're lame
[Laughter]
what's going on
i think a little bit about a little bit
he rolls his eyes at me all the time but
also like we have a really good
relationship that's tight so we get back
and then a week later this kid this
character x drops on a nifty gateway not
i buy it
and then i i somehow ended up like
getting his cell phone number and we
started chatting
and that's how like my nft story began
right and then so what before then you
didn't really you weren't in the nfl i
wasn't into nfts before i was in the
crypto and i was trading crypto and like
going you know this is recent then
because when we talked you were mainly
doing crypto and other accounting and
stuff right yeah yeah so very recent and
that's this is what i think is really
interesting about this web3 space is
things move so quickly and the thing is
like 3 rewards you for participating in
this ecosystem yeah and you see this
with all these other tokens and air
drops we'll talk about that some other
point but like so i bought his
and i put it in my wallet i was like
okay this is kind of cool and i dabbled
a little bit more nfts and then april
came around and for me like my tax
season ends april 15th
so tax season ended and i was like i'm
gonna buy myself the most ridiculous
thing ever to reward me for like getting
through another tax season and this one
board ape yacht club was just rolling
out
and so for me like when i was in bali
like i wear
okay little story i wear leopard print
yoga pants that's like my thing that's
his normal clothes
actually you guys you guys would be
friends really quick
so i love i love like leopard print and
there's like a whole nother story about
cats and [ __ ] like that
so like i ended up going on open sea and
this one opens you was still kind of
like fresh and new and i look up for ap
yacht club and i'm looking around and i
find this board ape yacht club of like
this leopard print ape with just like a
tank top all the time and it was half an
eighth and at the time like all he did
was i'm paying half an eighth for a jpeg
which is later like at the time i think
ethan was like three grand yeah half a
month 1500 bucks how much is it now okay
so i'll get to that part right yeah
oh jesus so i bought it for half an
ethan i thought that was the most
ridiculous thing ever i put in my
metamask wallet call it a day went back
to work and forgot about it bought a
couple of them or nfts over the
summertime and then so what ended up
happening was in the fall is when they
did the mutinate
drop
so that's that's what this logo is the
neon ape right and so what happened is
right before that i started getting
offers for 30 eth for 40 for this
right which is big money i mean you're
going from i literally spent and just
let's keep this in context right like
like nfts are very speculative right so
just to be responsible you're in
research this is not financial advice
but i'm a jpeg day jet deegen um
i was getting offers for anthony is so
horny right now
[Music]
you're basically cybering him right now
so i'm getting offers for fingering
myself
because i said a word dude
so i'm getting offers for like 120 000
dollars for for this jpeg holy crap
and then so i went on facebook and i
post on facebook guys i'm getting offers
for like this for this ape and a lot of
people don't get it and that's the thing
it's still very new this new technology
if you're a boomer like me i'm like what
the [ __ ] what are you talking about
you're a boomer
i'm a boomer dude are you he's a
millennial boom i'll pay like pay three
eath for like a pamela anderson poster
someone make that jpeg
all the import models come back and do
nfc projects they
i remember from hot import nights man
because all the nine needs to do is with
money now oh my god that's gonna touch
him from the corazon
touch them somewhere else so i was
getting so i put up on facebook and
everyone was like oh it's a scam it's a
bubble just sell it i'm like nah
whatever not i was joking my son was
like dude we're getting like big offers
for this and so my son he loves like the
audi rs6 wagon yeah he's like yes
you know we could sell that right now
and buy an rs6
i was like ah okay let's just like
listen hang on but like
so that night i was like let me just put
throw a ridiculous offer out there i'm
just gonna put my ape up for 50 each
which is like 150 000
big money right
we put up for 50 each just says like a
joke
and he sold right away i told my son it
was a joke
i went to sleep and when you're when you
need an nft space you just get so
immersed in it the first thing you
always do is you wake up and you look at
open sea right it's just like how like
how boomers like look at their
newspapers we wake up and look at ftx
yeah yeah you go you actually look at
your your crypto positions and
everything so i woke up and i was
looking at my opens he's like [ __ ] where
did my ape go did i get hacked so you
didn't even realize you bought some you
got it sold i had no idea oh and then i
looked at my my wallet there's 50 more
ethernet but did you realize that you
charged too low oh
so at the time that was an above market
offer so i was like [ __ ] oh and then so
i looked at who bought it yeah the chain
smokers oh [ __ ] today's video is brought
to you by kerology all right so me
believe it or not i'm almost 50 years
old just kidding i'm closer to maybe 40.
i've been using this for maybe the last
three years and i feel like it's been
curologizing my face i feel like thank
you very much i got preview best and
skin but it's a pretty awesome
skincare product because guys
let's face it
when we go into the store a lot of that
stuff doesn't look like it's made for us
it's very confusing okay to me there's
only one kind of moisturizer it's called
lotion that's all i know what to do i
just grab that i don't know what a face
wash is any of that stuff but curology
made this super easy and simple because
they basically have this website that
you can go in click around there's a
survey your goals what you want you for
your beautiful skin i say i want
anti-aging okay
i don't want to look like my age and a
lot of people don't want to a lot of
people don't want to look older than
they are okay i also have oily ass skin
help me out they created this formula
just for me it has my name on it it does
they send me a package here
with a moisturizer
face wash
puts the thinking in the box so i don't
even have to go to the store be like oh
i forgot my lotion right
and here we go discreet cool little box
comes to your front door
every single month
that's the best part that it's a
subscription so you don't even have to
go to the store and make that part of
your shopping list anymore either and
also you know how we'd be dry as hell in
the desert yep they got this lightsaber
looking chapstick that you can get
separately order you know and then it's
really good one hand operation because
what's the push thing you don't even
need to take the cap off
like that guys so if you want ultra easy
skin care that's actually made for your
skin curology is the way to go as you
can see you'll get a custom prescription
cream made for you by a dermatology
provider for your specific goals whether
it's tackling acne clogged pores skin
texture dark books fine lines or
something else you start by taking a
short online skin quiz and if that's a
good fit they'll ship you your formula
right to your door just like this
get started with curology just like i
did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com
off the record just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash off the record to start
your free 30-day trial cancel any time
prescription subject to consultation oh
i it was a blue check mark so i was like
i don't know so i went on twitter and dm
the chainsmokers and said hey i don't
know if it's you guys but somebody with
the chainsmoker's name bought my
leopardprint8 it was you guys i am super
appreciative of it you say i want it
back
it was a joke
here's a picture for reference
i'll buy you 55 for it i'll just send
you a screenshot of it we'll call it
yeah
right click save will be good
and then so they texted back and i'm
still having i still talk to them today
like i just text them today about the
ape thing so at the time it was a really
for me it was it was life and it is
life-changing money right to go from
like two grand to literally a hundred
forty hundred thousand dollars
life-changing money
but in retrospect now the floor is 110 e
oh my god right and today
they drop a token and people who are
holding the original eight they
literally got about a hundred thousand
dollars worth of token drop today
so i only had the mutant which is the
which is like the second generation of
it yeah so my airdrop that i got today
was 20 grand
which i mean 20 grand is a lot of money
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like i look back
and i'm like okay i lost effectively 100
i mean 50 50. for the difference of what
it's worth right now plus
100 grand of token how come you didn't
text me to buy some [ __ ]
i know man you respond you you you dm me
about my stories but don't tell me
nothing about the nft's man i think
would have told me out of like nah
right
if you would have told me i would have
been like i'll fit in my pam
poster
from vip not even baywatch but you know
like like just in the crypto space like
when people ask you about your crypto
positions and you tell them and then
they buy it later when it's super pumped
up exactly and it drops yeah they come
back to you as if like they're mad at
you they're mad at you oh dude you
should i'm completely opposite like i
never see i never tell anybody what to
buy ever because i that exactly i hate
that [ __ ] but people expect that i will
be that way and i'm like no no you don't
know me so you tell bart bar will be
like that's great advice i'm not gonna
buy it right
you tell me i'm gonna go let me get a
loan out for a hundred grand and i'm
gonna buy it right now and then a week
later he's like what is it again
ultimate that's like dj ultimate i just
pelosi everybody
so with like um you know when like
russia invaded ukraine and like stocks
dropped and everything do the prices of
nfts do they take a hit during that
period so what what's what you're seeing
is
there's a general pool of liquidity in
the market that's what a lot of us need
to understand what does that mean kind
of like flow of money like water around
going around yeah like
how you bring water into this
think of this cup as like the oh like
the total amount of liquidity in the
market like the amount of money in the
world the amount of money that's flowing
in the world might be so
okay so yours is a little bit darker and
larger
so when certain market events happen
people become more risk averse and they
pull liquidity out of the market they
cash out they cash out to get back in
cash positions for safety yeah so ends
up happening when that happens it causes
everyone else's sound that causes this
cascade of markets being affected across
the board right so you saw the stock
market cascading down you saw crypto
cascading down and nfts are inherently
much more speculative than even crypto
which is super speculative so it hits
even harder it hits even harder
but the same time too because nfts and
jpegs are fundamentally more illiquid
there is some kind of protection there
because like
people can't sell
even if they drop the price
so it holds kind of the value in its own
bizarre twisted way are you saying the
next time a con a country gets bombed i
should go on open c
kind of so i mean well i mean this this
happened when this happened when the
pandemic first happened right you could
see you could see the stocks just take
this crazy dive and then it went wow
exactly every single time there's like
red in the streets there's always the
time people are supposed to be yes yeah
how come it's not red more it is it's
hella red like the last three years have
been crazy we need freeways like just
falling apart or something
you're gonna be the guy you just moved
out of l.a i'm gonna put a [ __ ]
dynamite under the floor
that's what he does kills a bunch of
people looks at open c
it's not working yet bart's trying to be
like george soros right now and
destroyed nation so he can [ __ ] buy
low that's the plot of pelham one two
three literally oh really holy [ __ ] so
you can buy low yeah i don't got no
board apes or nothing but like at the
end of the day
at the end of the day like this is
really interesting emergency technology
you're buying into communities it's
crazy though though
the way that people are just like coming
up so hard on crypto even me too like
i'm like damn like the the po it's just
the volatility it's just [ __ ] crazy
like people what's your favorite part
he's like do you see how happy he is
about it you think stocks are risky man
this is a heart attack like every day it
is
my homie when i was first getting into
nfts too uh my homie put an analogy that
made sense uh to me like stocks it's
like it's like why would you buy [ __ ]
a jpeg for like thousands of dollars and
then it's like well
obviously it's speculat uh speculative
obviously it's a gamble in one sense but
in another sense it's if you actually do
the research and think about the people
behind that project it's like investing
into a stock it's like are you buying
three thousand dollars for like a stock
of that company understanding that the
future of whatever the culture the
branding the the adoption the the team
that is developing ship behind the
scenes or whatever are they going to
turn that into a much more you know a
valuable company in some way shape or
form like we were like we work exactly
and you got your crazy stuff you got
your things that are like fueled only on
hype that have like nothing behind it
they have no promises no road maps right
and those ones it's like it's all
speculative and if everybody loves it
they love it but there are a lot of
other projects out there that are if
they're
have an actual road map that has
something that is effective for the
people that buy into it
that's also really really cool to invest
in
and then there's also like 99 percent of
nfc projects that are rug pulls so yeah
yeah but i mean this happens in the
stuff
it's not like what i don't know why
people act like stocks are the only
things that are safe and then like
crypto is all like a ponzi scheme
because they had 100 years to look at it
but there's the same
scams and rug pulls and everything those
terms came from stocks you know what i
mean like
they did that in stocks with you know
they would pump and dump all those words
they came from the stock world so i
guess the only thing that's different i
guess is you have a tangible business
and this is what makes it less
speculative is like you're looking at a
market where there's industry or
whatever but still companies manipulate
their numbers
show you know please their stock like
owners and everything just so people
will pump that stock that's still a
strategy just as much as like pulling
out news for crypto and saying like hey
all this stuff is happening in crypto
right now buy this coin you know it's
it's like i don't really get that
difference where people make it seem
like it's two totally different things
but in my mind investing is pretty
similar if you look at the fundamentals
in all across the board yeah i will say
the uh obviously what makes it a lot
easier for stocks right and this is all
[ __ ] does [ __ ] but for the sake of
talking about layman's things it's like
one regulation right uh two a singular
currency so everybody understands every
single trade is like still acting on the
same currency and like almost
semi-consistent form of like evaluation
right and then uh on top of that too
it's like with stocks because they're
like quote unquote like publicly traded
right it's like the idea the idea of
like somebody behind the scenes pulling
like a stock company off the public
traded market and disappearing in some
decentralized way it's like that's not
that's not the same language or lingo
that is is
becoming familiarized with everybody in
the crypto scene nowadays or at least
the footers right so it's kind of like
and that happens that hell happens
people people get scammed like every
[ __ ] day in in the in the blockchain
space and yeah but that's also why
people are winning like crazy in the
blockchain space too you know so i think
too you're looking at different
economies of scale in terms of size
right so let's talk about this this dark
black coffee right so let's think of
this as like your general stock market
right now it's it's in the hundreds of
trillions of dollars of market cap of
all these companies everything and the
general market cap for crypto is under a
trillion dollars i believe it is true
yeah
so it's magnitude smaller but what that
also means is
the same amount of capital being
deployed in the crypto markets could
really influence the markets much more
heavily than in the general stock market
like if you go and you buy 10 million
dollars of apple stock it's gonna do
marginal
you know improvements to that the price
of the stock where people like oh
somebody bought 10 million of stock
which is not a big deal but if you went
and bought 10 million dollars of
luna for example somebody's gonna be
like due to whales in this thing and
everyone's gonna dog pile in and drive
the price of it up yeah that's true
because people don't really look at
market cap when they look at coins and
then like someone could
not easily influence bitcoin you could
have hundreds of millions of dollars and
not influence bitcoin as much
as let's say a [ __ ] coin that only has a
market cap of 100 million or even 10
million so if i come in with 1 million
and and that only has a 10 million
market cap like i'm gonna make movements
and then this is where people it's
called like rallying up and then like
they see the pump and they're like oh
wow i'm excited this coin is doing great
because it's gonna go from one dollar to
now three or whatever right but then
if you can't see if you don't understand
the market cap and the market size then
it it's easily like manipulated and the
biggest thing too is like there's this
this concept called survivorship bias
and survivorship bias and the whole
story behind it was like back in world
war ii
there's researchers that studied all the
airplanes are coming back from the war
and they're like hey how do we armor up
our planes more to make it more
effective and so the planes are coming
back they had bullets on the fuselage
and some of the wings and [ __ ] like that
so it's like oh let's arm up the
fuselage but there was this one
researcher and statistic statistician
that said no if they have all these
bullets that are in the fuselage and
made it back that's not the problem
the problem is you're getting too many
bullets in the engine we need to arm up
the engine so survivorship bias is we
see other people that that made 10 or 20
or 100 x on one random [ __ ] coin and we
believe that oh if we buy into this
token that we're gonna make this ton of
money too so there's definitely a lot of
human psychology in the markets that is
just super fascinating the more you
understand just how we think as humans
just like what you said with like
ukraine situation or war and you always
sell the news and you buy like when
everybody has blood in the street it's
it's all these things there's a lot of
psychology beyond just this technical
analysis of like oh there's the double
headed shoulder wave or whatever it is
yeah there's human psychology we gotta
get good at manipulating people
the unfortunate part but yes yeah there
is definitely a facet of that in these
small markets right
that plays a really big role
[Music]
you